how did you first get started like
making these videos yeah so a platform
called vine came out and it was like the
first time people could just like six
seconds yeah six seconds that's all john
ever needed
in his sex life
a few of them were longer
and it was like the first time that you
can make you know at home videos without
having a big production like this and uh
so i started just you know popping off
things and then i'm looking at the couch
right now with lou and ross and ferguson
and sami sam
and i
it's just
it looks like a really weird porn
[Laughter]
yeah i mean that's kind of we were in
the airport the other day and it was
like awful we were getting bombarded by
uh fans and whatnot and then i thought
about it i was like there's no way
we could like hide no matter what we did
well they could these two
they put a trench coat on maybe stacked
on top and like how he just said the
porn we get offered it a lot you know do
you get offered porn a couple times a
week probably are you serious couple
times a week probably how would you get
offered like what would they phone you
or they dm you dm on instagrams and they
want us two together
and offer big bucks you have your phone
on you yeah read some of the dms i want
to hear at the porn offers i've never
actually seen a porn offer yeah awesome
number one
would you do it for the right money um
of course yeah of course ferguson the
kid what would you say the right money
is though you have to say yeah
oh no probably a hundred thousand
dollars plus no way you would do porn
for a hundred thousand dollars it also
depends on what kind of porn we are
doing well they want the two of you
together i think you know what kind of
porn they want you know well say that's
not
that's not our first time let's just say
that oh yeah like what
what talk about this on here if this is
pg john's velocity this is not pg well
no i know okay so quickly i'll just get
straight to the point john john and i
have had a three-way before ah
multiple times yeah
more than once you're making me feel
small
oh my god
well they're looking for a new uh cast
member
what do you mean you had a three-way was
it was the third one was it a female yes
yes it was you're looking at me like
don't be an idiot yeah
don't worry you guys didn't touch each
other yeah i know so how did that come
did you get wait
what did they do paintbrush oh no that
doesn't work there has to be this oh
okay the paintbrush yeah are you okay
does she want a drink or something no i
was just giving her earmuffs
she doesn't want to hear her adopted
grandchildren about her stories no but i
want to see i want you're not you didn't
read the dms what people are offering we
started talking about the three ways
however the threesome actually happened
however the threesome actually happened
in her room at the airbnb but she was
away so i don't think she knew
granny
in her room yeah she was in her bed we
were yeah except afterwards we clean the
sheets so it's all good it's like it
never happened was there a mess was
there a big mess no no no
i'm a clean guy oh my god wow man
taking all that out so much for
political correctness
i was asking your son and seth was like
hey what's you know the vibe on here and
should we talk about this situation and
we're like it probably won't come up but
immediately like five minutes in it
comes up what do you mean you you when
my son alex who's there he he he's the
one who connected with you and says yeah
yeah they worked together and they said
come on ross and it's granny yeah we
thought maybe we'd talk about grandma's
crazy you know like life you know work
in world war ii and stuff and then
they're like i will talk about that
but right away
granny do i call her granny what is your
first thing
granny yeah yes but before we talk to
you about what you did during world war
ii yes we're talking to them about their
sex life oh wait a minute it's
non-existent which happened in your bed
not a good thing no i know i know but
they clean the sheets they cleaned the
sheets
before you got back that's why we had to
wash the sheets last night yeah i'm
sorry
who was the girl um she was actually a
friend of ours that also has dwarfism oh
sorry i'm gonna grab your hand there
while they're done
i'm used to it when we had the threesome
yeah that was the first time i met ross
uh-huh so wait that's a four-semester
this happened multiple times and i just
woke up the next day ready for we so i
brought him out to new york
i gotta be strategic here i brought them
out to new york for uh uh shoot for a
three-way
yeah yeah and then we filmed maybe three
episodes of the show it was for facebook
um like their long form
and we went out for drinks one night and
i said all right i'm going back it's
like we have a we have to get up at
seven and we get the
calls at eight uh they're like yeah
we'll be right after you i'm just like
all right over home and then i'll see
you guys
next morning john text me said come down
someone wants me i'm like somebody it's
just you and sammy you know and i walked
there and
lo and behold there was a
another three musketeer in that group
and uh
that was the first time and then you
know the second time we're out in la
maybe like you know what does she do for
a living um she's actually in college
still she's getting her master's degree
in what oh my god um psychology actually
should we phone her she wants
that's a tall order right there if you
want blue
[Laughter]
how old are you i'm 29. and how old is
i'm 22. henry and paul
24 all right
i like that name honestly i like you
better than ferguson yeah why you don't
like do they call you fergie yeah you're
not to be confused with the
licious that's what i would have called
you you're delicious
he came up with that name when you sat
on his lap
it's okay
that happened again no yeah with the
same person yeah and i was once again we
had another shoot the next day and i
went to bed early and i woke up that's
fine i walked upstairs i won't give her
name i don't even know i feel like
that's a can of worms nobody else do we
want to open yeah it's i don't know
let's sit on it for a little bit her
name's not important
yeah but what if she you know maybe she
doesn't want to talk about who knows why
wouldn't she talk about the three ways
she had with you guys twice
that's a six way
is there more than twenty they call it
the math not to make a joke they call it
a one and a half way but yeah
half half half so how do you guys decide
what end or who goes first or how does
that work those are good questions one
john's kind of scared of me a little bit
so you're the more dominant yeah i just
have to get right to it and like i'm
doing this and then ferguson you'll say
ferguson yeah take clean up man it's
like first
so you're the closer yeah you know a lot
of people call that sloppy seconds
granny you know what i'm talking about
right no yeah it's okay sloppy joe good
stuff yeah great delicious dish right
yeah
great
dish yes
so do you are you uh serious about this
woman no no not at all
how did you meet her
um actually we met her so we go to a
convention every year it's the little
people of america convention i've been
there
really no
we go there every year and it's a whole
thing with a bunch of other dwarfs
yeah big deal we have a small deal we
have dances we have competitions
we have a lot of alcohol a lot of them
alcohol then so you can just how many
people attend this
probably about roughly 3 500. 3 500 and
they're all little and you guys couldn't
find your own girl
each
there's 35
people drinking and dancing and you're
sharing one woman twice
i i've never thought about it that way
howie okay
i've heard of it and that's what's
happening if i could i'd like to
understand the purpose of this
convention is it because you're all
similar yeah it's all to spread
awareness about dwarfism
amongst other dwarfs yeah pretty much
because if it was like they went to a
convention and i was there you know i'd
be blocking all their shots so they want
you know even playing field yeah so
now all 3 500 of you understand
each other yeah you have similarities
yeah exactly yeah differences
so explain a bit more of it like it's a
huge orgy yeah no
wait do you say organization or whatever
i love i always get those two things
mixed up organization and orgy
granny what is it an organization or an
orgy it's an organ organization or orgy
yeah i've never been there either
you've never been going on here no no
i'm going to go this year but not for
their purpose i just want to you know
you want to you want to funny
[Music]